(cheering)
- Seventh's not that bad.
Plus, he just qualified
for the paralympics.
Every four years, we
spend two weeks watching
athletes compete for a
chance to be on a box
of disgusting cereal
that nobody's bought
since the '50s.
Who wants to spend
two weeks in London?
The food sucks, it's
always raining, and
no one looks like
Christian Bale.
It's just like Boston
with a big clock.
The Olympics haven't
been fun since '92
when the Dream Team
destroyed every country
they played by 40 points
and impregnated half
the bitches in Barcelona.
Yeah.
It's not a coincidence
that Spain suddenly
started cranking out
beautiful mixed race ballers.
The Greeks only invented
the Olympics because
they needed something
to watch while eating
their delicious salads.
That's why I decided to
get in on this action
and do every single
sport in the Olympics
in record time for the 2012
tosh point O-lympic games.
- [Announcer] Here is Daniel
Tosh with an affinement
warm-up routine that has
this announcer fully aroused.
He loads into the
blocks in the historic
tosh point O-lympiad
is under way.
A ridiculously short
dash into the hurdles,
into the high jump.
He's no stranger to
working the pole.
Is it the shoes?
Clips the crossbar.
And waiting for him on
the pad is a wrestler.
Let's get it on.
It's over.
Four gold so far.
Can he make it five?
Tosh floats like a
butterfly, stings like VD.
Judo?
Now he's just piling on.
(yells)
It's as if he's been
training all morning.
He looks dead.
That's gonna make
the rematch tricky.
Time to throw stuff.
He chucks the metal frisbee.
The metal softball.
Tosh races through
the field events
like a ferral chested [Bleep].
Oh, hits his head
on the release.
Can we see a replay?
No?
Okay.
Forehand followed by a backhand.
Then a two handed
backhand into a
whatever the hell that is.
A big shove.
The judges aren't
going to like that.
[Bleep] It.
YOLO.
He clings it.
He jerks it.
And even has time to
get a quick nap in.
This is where Tosh truly
excels, handling balls.
Spikes the volleyball
right into a rented Camera.
Water Polo ball fake
and a header for a goal.
And look out, Dream
Team, because Daniel
just brought the house down.
Chalks up for gymnastics.
And let's just say
he powdered his nose
for a little extra energy.
Take that, G series.
(whimsical flute)
Just delightful.
Suck a bag of tits, China.
Bela Karolyi right out
to congratulate him.
Must me nice to hug a man
and not a 12 year-old girl
that will never have a period.
That counts as equestrian?
Seems like a stretch.
Remember, nobody needs an
assault rifle for any reason.
He'll probably get a low
score because of that splash,
but doesn't seem to
bother him as he swims
to the end of the pool and
right into sailing and rowing.
And here it is, the final
leg of the Dan-cathlon.
Yes, he's done it.
The judges are factoring
in time, distance,
and degree of difficulty.
Daniel Tosh just
made Michael Phelps
look like a lazy bitch.
What a great day for America.
- I just completed all the
Olympic events in record time.
Now can we start
football season?
It's the only sport
Americans care about.
(cheering)
I don't know why everyone's
so upset about blood doping.
Makes sports so much easier.
(energetic techno)